wiping
over
the footwear. Now,
this is traditionally
an issue that is often confused by a lot
of people, but it's not confusing.
I've been teaching this issue and this
book really for
about 20 years and
as long as we understand the basic
principles, the basic tenants
that these
acts of worship are built on, the rest
are
very understandable.
It's important for us
in our worship of Allah
to not differentiate
between the Sunnah
and that which is bare minimum
acceptable.
We don't want to do that.
Meaning whenever we go to do anything,
any act of worship, any act of worship,
it is
not the teachings of the Quran and
Sunnah to approach that act of worship
with the attitude of
I'm only going to do what I have to
and what I don't have to, I'm going to
avoid cuz
you know, I'm not going to do anything
extra. This is
a very
poor
attitude we have to scrub away out of
our hearts. Whenever you approach
Allah Rabbil Alameen in his court,
you approach with the best that you
have. What does Allah Subhana
Wa Ta'ala tell us?
Wa'mur qawmaka ya'khudhu
bi'ahsaniha.
Even Allah Subhana wa ta'ala, he
commanded Musa
when he gave him the the laws, he said,
"And instruct your people to follow the
best of it."
The best of it, the best of all of it.
To do their best in every single aspect,
to do the best of it.
Now, this verse has many meanings.
But one of the big differences between
this ummah, or we should say those who
succeeded in this ummah, and the
failures of the previous nations
is
a lack of enthusiasm
to holding to that which is best.
You always want to do what is best, what
is most complete, the most you can do in
that particular thing.
If we were to break down salah, for
instance,
and say this is obligatory, this is
mustahab,
and I'm only going to really do what is
obligatory, but mustahab, you know,
someone else somewhere is doing it. This
is a failure.
This is a failure. The companions
radiyallahu anhum did not differentiate
between obligatory and
preferred, except in one instance.
What instance do we differentiate
between
obligatory and preferred? In the
instance of failure, or an inability to
fulfill the entirety of something.
When we miss something by accident, then
we go and we look, did I miss something
that is obligatory? Do I need to do it
over?
Or is it acceptable?
So, we don't look to that which is
obligatory and mustahab as we're
approaching to do something.
We only look at it if we fail in
fulfilling something.
Based on that,
what is the Sunnah of wiping over the
footwear?
I'm going to show you exactly how the
prophet Sallallahu alayhi wasallam
wiped over his socks or shoes or leather
I think we should not call them leather
socks because it gives the wrong idea.
Leather moccasins, let's say, right?
Hard leather footwear.
Here's how he did it.
When he would
put his footwear on, he would make wudu
completely.
So, he would have wudu.
Then he would put
the socks. He's been narrated to have
wiped over socks, cotton socks,
wool socks, all kinds of socks,
or
shoes. And shoes
have a sole on the bottom. A detached
sole, that's a difference between a a
shoe and other types of footwear. And
most usually wipe over his khuff, which
is a khuff is a hard leather
that is worn instead
of shoes. It's never worn with shoes.
It's worn instead of shoes. That is a
khuff. And we'll get into that. The
material is inconsequential. It does not
matter.
The material does not matter. What
matters is
the spirit of the act
of the act of worship. And what is the
spirit?
If we have something that is covering
the place where we are
supposed to wash,
and it is a hassle to remove it every
time we make wudu, we can wipe over it.
Right?
And so, he would make full wudu
and he would put any of these types of
footwear on.
Then he would go about his prayers. The
next time he would
make wudu
he would make full wudu
and after wiping his head and his ears,
he would take water, wet his hands
again.
Okay? And then he would wipe over his
footwear exactly this.
Right?
That's it.
I'll show you again.
Okay? He would
He's making wudu. He wipes over his
head, his ears, take water again.
At the same time not right and then
left, not two hands on each foot, not
the bottom, not the sides, not like
this.
Just this. Toes forward
fingers towards the toes.
Wipe up one time.
That's it.
That's how he would wipe. He would never
wipe more than once.
And it doesn't matter how much is wiped.
What matters is that the symbol of
wiping occurs. That's all that matters.
This is not meant to clean the physical
footwear.
This is not meant to take the place of
washing in the sense that it has the
same physical effect
on the footwear as washing. That's not
what it's meant for. You make wudu like
this, wet his hands, and then
wipe over just that. And then he would
go about his day, right? Nothing more
than that.
Nothing more, nothing less.
He would not do right and then left.
Mhm. He would wipe simultaneously.
He would wipe over the tops.
Fingers towards the
toes.
And he would wipe his footwear
if he happened to be wearing his
footwear when it was time to make wudu.
And he would wash his feet if he
happened to not be wearing any footwear
when it is time to make wudu. This is an
important distinction that Ibnul Qayyim
[Silence]
That is how he made wudu. Now,
for 24 hours
from the moment that he first wiped over
his footwear. Notice, when does the
timer start?
It starts the first time he wipes over
them.
The first time he makes wudu and wipes
over his footwear instead of
washing his feet.
That's when it starts.
A full day and night
for a resident, 3 days and 3 nights for
a traveler.
Travel and residence has changed a lot
since then.
I doubt any of us here is going to even
wear his socks or
shoes
to bed, right? Or is going to
not take their footwear off for an
entire 24 hours. Or if you're traveling
to not
take a shower or bathe or change your
socks for 3 days and 3 nights. However,
that is the bare minimum.
And so the Prophet Sallallahu alayhi
wasallam, he taught the companions that
the only time a person would have to
take these
these socks off or shoes off or
to wash the feet
is
one of two instances.
Number one, because he has to make
ghusl.
Now you have to wash. You can't wipe
over your footwear in ghusl.
Number two, the time ran out and he has
to reset the time.
That's the only two times.
Now here's a question.
This is a question that comes up often.
We already discussed what breaks your
wudu, correct?
What are the things that we mentioned
that breaks your wudu?
Al kharij min as-sabilayn. So anything
that comes out of the front or back
private parts, okay? That's one and two.
Number three.
Deep sleep. Very good.
Number four.
Hm?
Eating camel meat?
Okay.
Passing out, which is like
losing consciousness, which is like
sleep, okay? And one more.
Nope.
Those don't break your wudu.
It is the sunnah to make wudu after
these things, but it's not obligatory.
We mentioned
touching the private parts
with sexual intent, with arousal,
directly,
in one opinion. Okay.
Does taking your socks off break your
wudu?
Listen to the question.
Did the Sheikh forget?
Or what is going on here? Does taking
your socks off break your wudu?
If you make wudu
and you wipe over your socks,
then as you're coming to the masjid, you
step in a mud puddle. Dag on it. Now you
got to take your socks off. You come
into the masjid, you take the socks off,
you put them in the shoes, you walk into
the masjid. Do you still have wudu?
You say yes? What do you say? No?
No?
Yes?
If you say no,
you don't have wudu, that means taking
your socks off breaks your wudu.
If you said yes,
you still have wudu,
that means
that taking the socks off doesn't
interfere with the wudu that you have.
And that is what is correct.
Taking the footwear off does not
interfere with your wudu. Your wudu is
not connected
to the footwear.
What is connected is wiping on the
footwear again. This is the difference.
So you come in, you take your socks off,
you still have wudu. You have wudu as
long as you don't break your wudu. But
when you break your wudu,
now you have to wash your feet again.
You can't wipe over those socks again
cuz you took them off.
So, your wudu is not connected to
your socks being on or off. Your wudu
is fine.
What is is the ruling of wiping over
that footwear again. Because remember,
you have to have
washed your feet
to put socks on to then wipe over them.
You still have wudu. You put the socks
back on after the prayer, after you
leave the masjid or whatever in our
hypothetical. You put the socks back on.
Sure, you still have wudu. You have wudu
for a whole other 10 hours until you
break your wudu.
But then if you were to go wipe over
those socks again, did you put those
socks on after having washed your feet
in that scenario?
What's the answer?
You came in, you took them off.
Then you put them back on. Did you Did
you put them back on while having wudu
after washing your feet?
No. Pay attention, guys.
No, you didn't. That is the condition.
The Prophet Sallallahu alayhi wasallam
is making wudu. Jarir ibn Abdullah is
there. He's helping him. He's pouring
the water for for wudu. He wipes over
his head. Jarir goes to take off his
footwear for him. And he says,
"Leave them on."
fa inni labis
tuhuma
tahiratain.
He said, "Leave them because I put them
on after having wudu.
Right? So, what's the condition now?
I can only wipe over the footwear
if I had put them on after having washed
my feet for wudu.
That's the condition.
If you understand these things that I
just mentioned to you right now, you
took 90% of all the rulings of wiping
over the footwear. It's not hard, right?
So, now when we get into the
technicalities, just keep these
principles that I just told you in mind.
[Silence]
[Arabic recitation]